il n'y a pas accès même s'il ya des
millions de téléspectateurs
je sais pas moi quelqu'un ce que les
indicateurs ont comme influence sur les
gens et l'opinion publique parce que je
pense quand même c'est que macron à une
tête de ça va mieux quand hollande dit
ça va mieux les gens ne croient pas pour
le moment qu'en macron dit ça va mieux
pour la cei ne dit pas les gens autour
de lui le disent à leur place hilali
laquelle c'est dans deux ans il se fixe
aussi la camry physiquement la réforme
c'est comme gp incarner physiquement
l'impôt c'est comme ça donc après on
verra on verra si c'est de ça mais voilà
on verra si ça fonctionne mais moi ce
qui me frappe dans l'exercice du pouvoir
et je pense que c'est ça qui fait aussi
qui remonte c'est qu'il a trouvé
vraiment la distance suffisante
justement avec le pouvoir nous de presse
précédent président de la république
donnait l'impression d'être des
jouisseurs il n'arrivait pas à
dissimuler le fait qu'ils jouissaient du
fait d'être là où il était hélas lui
donne l'impression d'être concentré sur
ces dossiers alors peut-être que c'est
un magnifique comédien peut-être que
c'est réel et donc les gens disent on
verra alors après peut-être que dans 18
mois ou dans deux ans il y aura une
lassitude s'il ne voit pas dans leur vie
quotidienne que les indicateurs qu'on
leur monde s'applique à lui même ce
qu'il a dit ce ministre
ils sont pas là pour être assis dans
leurs fauteuils
la situation oui il ya vraiment un
rapport au pouvoir une forme de liturgie
du pouvoir qui était restaurée avec lui
et qui pour le moment fait que les
phrases qui reviennent dans le langage
courant s'est il nous fait pas honte on
a l'impression qu'il fait son travail
donnant lui sa chance
chose que l'on n'entendait pas